[Musique]
le tableau attention je prenais des
questions sur la carrière de pagaille de
daniel les accords si la personne donc
vous n'arrive pas à dépasser la moyenne
elle sera collée à la si elle y arrive
et vous désignerez la personne qui sera
collée pendant la pub on va rendre
hommage à daniel levy et paga la
personne va devoir se déguiser en
maurice pendant la pub chanté des titres
de la comédie musicale les dix
commandements avec l'accent marseillais
voilà c'est dur sera encore pas s'ils
n'ont pas de motif pour peu cher à la
casse va manger une petite school irada
bon autant vous dire que ça va être très
triste je fais attention sur daniel lévy
en quelle année a eu lieu la première de
la comédie musicale les dix
commandements tâche et 2004 2004 daniel
2000-2002 me
[Applaudissements]
il y avait un débat son sujet c'est tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord 1-0 sur un
an souvient notamment de ce spectacle
oui on va revoir votre duo avec la
chanson mon frère je l'adoré c'est sûr
mais mon frère si on mène le petit coq
jacques et bien sûr on reverra longue il
aimait et j'avais le dilemme et hemani
sont percées des boissons on y voit
jenny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez ça les dix commandements
oui c'était un peu moins jeunes as well
as bien sûr tu es venu reconnaître héros
tu cours dans la 6e ou pas s'est
apprécié à tort il est beau il est très
beau j'adore ça va je devrais bon on
dirait un choc et j'adore récemment les
dix commandements survenu avec un
nouveau casting jal expliqué que vous
n'étiez pas plutôt courant de ce nouveau
casting et de ce retour des dix
commandements en fait j'étais chez moi
quand j'ai vu chez toi oui ma tronche ma
voix et puis daniel revue une lévy
revient c'est dans les dix commandements
gabon une première nouvelle je suis pas
au courant c'est en fait non non il y
avait un convoi un petit quiproquo on va
dire à moi c'est ça c'est assez c'est
assez
très bien mais si ça c'est assez simple
notion dans quelle ville habité le
marseillais paga à ses débuts en télé
réalité enfin j'hésite entre deux villes
j'avoue de plex way et montauban et je
dirais plutôt masculine des docks est
bonne pas du tout non tu tout habité au
fond me chauffer marseille non non
pépin des pommes juste à côté de
malaunay portrait on a récupéré les
images à quoi ils ces pépins ou qu'on ne
savait même pas que ça existait oui ça
existe mais bien sûr vous siffle pas
sauf que les pépins le monde connaît les
hyper bien que les pékinois épinoy
regarder
[Musique]
voilà je m'appelle
j'ai 24 ans j'habite pépin ok faut aller
voir une fille je veux faire avec le mot
j'y vais avec humour j'ai la pêche je
suis né comme ça merci papa merci maman
la mélamine dans le club à part ça vous
fait pas mention
troisième question dans quel sens on
dans quelque sens sont surprenants
peut-on entendre la voix de daniel
déduit ce rêve bleu bo le lavabo on va à
la pêche ce rêve bleu
bien sûr je kiffe et cette chanson je
vais t'offrir un monde et où il reconnu
tout dit c'est pas lui regardez on a la
vidéo on a la preuve en images
[Musique]
c'est pas
mon dos
non
[Musique]
pour eux
je vais t'offrir un bon mois ces mots là
c'est un cauchemar affreux le mois ce
monde offre le mois c'est monde je vais
t'offrir un monde à offrir un bon on va
pas se voir beaucoup tueurs à gage était
un poisson visage d'une de ses camarades
qui s'agissait-il à jouer maintenant
maintenant si vous répondez bien
maintenant c'est bon allez jade jada née
et danses étaient regardés parfois
[Musique]
je n'ai fini mais je vois ce têt by
annoncé déclencher une guerre sur
facebook live puisqu'il a tout perdu il
n'a pas de sens